Pearl was born sometime around 1898 give
or take a couple years in rural Texas as
the only child of first generation and
German immigrants she was raised on a
farm with a strict Protestant upbringing
her parents prayed before every meal and
disciplined Pearl harshly when she
stepped out of line This continued well
into Pearl's adulter Pearl's childhood
was presumably quite lonely there's no
mention of siblings cousins or friends
of any kind in Pearl's life it seems her
only friends are the farm animals and
the alligator that lives in her swamp
Pearl's imagination was a refuge for her
growing up she imagined a life for
herself outside the farm and she became
obsessed with that dream there was also
a darker side to Pearl her mother
mentions terrible things that she's seen
her do in private presumably to the farm
animals Pearl even admits to this
herself first it was only animals
smaller than myself
nothing with feelings nothing that could
hurt me back in her teenage years Pearl
met a young farmhand named Howard who
came from an affluent background and
chose to work on Pearl's Family Farm
Pearl pursued him and they fell in love
she hoped that Howard would take her off
the farm and show her a better life they
got married in the mid-1910s and even
tried to start a family but Pearl
miscarried shortly after Howard was
drafted to fight in World War one which
would have happened in 1917 or 1918.
once again Pearl's dreams were put on
hold and she was trapped at home with
her parents Pearl dreamed of a life
outside the farm but that dream was
always just Out Of Reach she imagined
one life but reality handed her the same
one that she'd always know this repeated
heartbreak turned into rage and combined
with her constant isolation from the
rest of the world led her to do horrible
horrible things if you want to know why
Pearl did the things she did and how her
own actions kept her trapped on the farm
until her death in 1979 stick around to
the end of this video
[Music]
welcome to Horror history by this point
you may be wondering what's with the
tank top where's the usual Horror
history shirt in time you need to be
dress coded sir well today I am wearing
this to let you know about the all new
series
it's that time of year for shows and
festivals so I put together a product
line with everything you'll need tank
tops teas and even a hoodie to keep you
warm during that last set of the night
but the daisies World metal merch is
only available for a limited time once
it's gone it's gone Link in the
description Pearl is the antagonist of
Thai West 2022 film acts and the
villainous protagonist of the prequel
appropriately titled Pearl in 1918 The
World At Large had fallen on Hard Times
America joined World War One in 1917 and
the very real flu pandemic took the
lives of over 675 000 Americans there
were no laborers around to help with
farm work on account of the war and by
this time Pearl's father was infirm and
paralyzed all of the farmwork and
responsibilities to keep the family
alive fell squarely on the shoulders of
Pearl and her Stern German mother
Pearl's life mostly consisted of
attending to the animals reading old
letters from her husband and taking care
of and bathing in front of her dad you
know normal stuff one a bright spot in
her life was going to the Picture Show
movies were brand new in 1918 and pearl
loved them she even named her animals
after the the silent movie stars Charlie
Chaplin and Mary Pickford Pearl dreamed
of becoming a star herself one day and
became obsessed with this idea but to
fully understand how Pearl turns from a
dreamer to a killer we've got to take a
closer look at her dreams and fantasy
foreign
she's dressed up and doing her hair in a
three-sided vanity mirror she closes her
eyes and gets lost in her Daydreams the
lights go out and the spotlight shines
brightly on her as she dances center
stage in her own imagination it's
magical but like all of the good things
in Pearl's life it doesn't last long
Pearl's Daydream is interrupted by her
mother who scolds her for wearing her
old address causing Pearl to storm out
of the house and overalls and head to
the barn to feed and perform for the
animals they are Pearl's captive
audience literally
[Music]
the performance is ruined by a goose who
wanders in and steals the spotlight this
is the first time that we see another
darker side to Pearl her disdain is
written all over her face she stabs the
goose with her pitchboard and feeds it
to her alligator despite the fact that
her mother knows about her violent
tendencies she never tries to intervene
until it's too late since she's isolated
from the rest of the world she never
faces any repercussions and never learns
to deal with her problems in a healthy
way this problem would fester and only
get worse the longer that she was stuck
at the farm Pearl rides her bike into
town to buy her father's Morphine at the
low low price of two beds how much is
two bits you ask famously it's the price
of a shave in a haircut
and here
[Music]
well today 100 bits is the equivalent of
1.40 on Twitch back then two bits was a
slang term for 25 cents Pearl buys the
medicine and uses the spare change to
get into the picture house across the
streets that's the movie theater she
sees a war movie where a soldier gets
his face melted off not the type of
thing you'd expect to see in a silent
movie and pearl is sipping her father's
morphine throughout the show so it seems
likely that this movie is at least
partly a product of Her Imagination on
top of that this movie and the next one
feature sound and movies weren't
screened with sound until 1923. this
could be an oversight but it could be an
indication that Pearl is projecting a
bit see what I did there I'm projecting
the next thing she sees is Palace
Follies a movie featuring A Chorus Line
of dancing girls enamored she takes the
program and heads to a back alley to
look it over where she first meets The
projectionist Who flirts with her and
gives her a cigarette she even cuts out
a frame of the film reel and gives it to
her as a souvenir they chat and the
projectionist tells her to take pride in
caring for her dad but advises her not
to forget to live her own life too he
says all the things that Pearl has been
dying to hear and he leaves her an open
invitation to knock on his door anytime
as she rides her bike home with images
of the palace Valley's girls dancing in
her head a gust of wind carries her
souvenir film splice into a cornfield so
she goes searching for it and stumbles
upon the perfect outlet for her
loneliness a scarecrow may I have this
dance and they dance Pearl's dangerously
active imagination is showcased as she
gets lost in Romance she kisses the
Scarecrow and pictures the projectionist
face on it her darker side slips out
then she humps it and steals its hat
scarecrow if you're watching this I know
you probably like that hat but some
people you sleep with just steal your
clothes just be thankful she didn't
steal your Blackhawks hoodie back home
her mother scolds her for being late and
for wearing a dirty hat she once again
bathes in front of her dad this time
strangling him a bit just to see if
he'll react which of course he cannot
then it's dinner time after a Stern
prayer Pearl's mom interrogates her over
the eight cents that she spent on the
movie to give you an idea of how much
they were hurting financially that's the
equivalent of 1.72 in 2023. Pearl lies
and says that she spent it on candy so
her mom takes away her dinner and
explains that she won't allow Pearl to
wander around in foolish fantasies and
hide from her responsibilities any
longer hurl goes up to her room and
prays
we'll start the world
so that I'll make it far far away from
this place
amen Pearl's desperation for stardom was
turning into her only Escape which was
bad news for anyone who tried to get in
her way
the next morning Pearl's Cow Milking is
interrupted when she gets a visit from
her well-to-do sister Mitzi who arrives
in a fancy car wearing fox fur and a
nice dress mitzi's mother gives Pearl's
family a roasted pig which Pearl's
mother refuses out of stubborn pride and
leaves on the front porch Pearl and
Mitzi talk of it smitsy is the closest
thing Pearl has to a friend they relate
to one another but maybe not quite to
the degree that Mitzi expects all this
isolation has been enough to make one
man it hasn't
it really has while X and pearl were
sets during the 1918 flu pandemic they
were released in 2022 during the covid
pandemic and this scene highlights a
parallel between each time period
showing how the rich and poor were both
isolated but what that means for each of
them is very different then Mitzi drops
a bombshell on Pearl there's a dance
audition coming up at her church for a
Christmas Chorus Line that'll tour the
South Pearl used this as her big break
and agrees to meet Mitzi there she
steals her mother's dress once again in
Daydreams of dancing on the big screen
later that night she sneaks out to the
picture house where Cleopatra starring
theta-bera is listed on the Marquee
we'll get back to that name in a little
bit Pearl knocks on the projectionist
door they share a drink and he shows her
a different kind of movie a stag film
according to director Ty West this is a
real stag film from the 1910s called a
free ride and it's believed to be the
first ever these types of films were
illegal at the time so they could only
be screened in private but Pearl is
still fascinated by whatever she sees on
the big screen and because she sees
herself as a star she eventually
imagines herself in that role which
would come into play later in her store
the projection is Pearl why she doesn't
just leave her situation and pearl says
that she can't while her parents are
still alive and that's when the light
bulb goes off if only they would just
die the following morning Pearl gets
right to work she takes her dad out to
the pier to take a closer look at the
alligator which by the way is named
just like theta-bera from Cleopatra this
moment with her father and the alligator
marks a turn for Pearl she knows what
she wants and she recognizes that life
on the farm is keeping her from
achieving her dreams and for the first
time she's doing something about it she
pushes her dad to the edge of the pier
and sends her goodbyes it'd be easier
for me if I didn't feel like I was
abandoning you you understand that I
love you Daddy but this is no way to
live once again her mother interrupts
Pearl's fun and probably theta's launch
why do you hate me Mom
I only want what's best
when do I get what I want whatever
screws were loose in Pearl's head before
are rattling around freely now she
becomes incense and a little aimless she
steals an alligator egg from theta's
nest and brings it to the bar she melts
down in front of Charlie and Mary and in
a fit of rage she squeezes the egg and
imagines her husband returning home from
the war and exploding at dinner Pearl's
mom confronts her with the palace
Follies program and pearl informs her
that she's going to a dance audition the
next day explaining that she needs to
try out or she's gonna regret it for the
rest of her life this is when Pearl
learns that her mother knows about some
of the horrible things she does when she
thinks nobody is watching her mother
says the thing that Pearl does not want
to hear
only a matter of time before you hurt
someone else the wording implies that
she's hurt someone before but we don't
know exactly who she's talking about it
could be an animal her husband or maybe
she's the reason that her dad is
paralyzed or maybe she's not referring
to a physical hurt but given her history
I somehow doubt that's the case as far
as we know Pearl has only killed animals
up to this point whatever the case she's
on the ropes here and her mother doesn't
instill a lot of confidence but when you
fail and you would fail I want you to
remember what it feels like
because that's how I feel every time
this causes Pearl to snap she slaps her
mother and the fight commences until
eventually Pearl shoves her into a
fireplace and drags her burnt body into
the basement as her father looks on in
horror Pearl's violent outbursts are
motivated by her desire to escape her
situation so to cope with this she turns
to a different kind of escape and heads
to the movies that night she sleeps with
the projectionist and dreams of dancing
on the big screen and her mother's burnt
face the next morning the morning of the
audition he gives her a ride home and so
Begins the most awkward morning after of
his short life where he's invited past
the maggot infested Pig that is still
sitting on the front porch to meet her
horrified father who is still sitting at
the dinner table Pearl drags the
projectionist upstairs where she kisses
him and talks of running away together
forever the mood is further ruined by
Pearl's mom moaning like a banshee in
the basement which the projectionists
insists they investigate so she tells
him that it's just the dog locked up in
the cellar this works for the time being
but Pearl is not a great liar because
later while introducing him to all of
her animals in the barn AKA her best
audience she instinctively tells him
that she doesn't have a dog when he asks
about it this is when the projectionist
understandably makes up an excuse to get
the hell out of Dodge when Pearl
recognizes that he's lying she turns on
him real quick you're lying
I'm not yes you are I know because I
feel things very deeply this is one of
our first Clues as to what might
actually be going on with pearl it's
pretty clear that she suffers from some
kind of mental illness and possibly more
than one but this line might indicate
that Pearl has borderline personality
disorder no I'm not a psychologist and
even psychologists have trouble
diagnosing BPD at times but she does
demonstrate symptoms like extreme anger
extreme emotional swings from extreme
closeness to extreme dislike basically
everything is Extreme pair that with a
distorted self-image impulsive behavior
and issues around abandonment and it's
likely that this diagnosis would apply
to Pearl
you're scaring me girl that's not to say
that people with borderline personality
disorder are murderers but in Pearl's
case she definitely is as the
projectionist would soon find out when a
pitchfork goes through his chest she
screams at him stating that nothing and
nobody is going to keep her on the farm
and finishes by sending the Pitchfork
right through his face with a stop after
heading back inside to say her goodbyes
and tie up any Loose Ends before her
life as a church dancer begins she bids
her mother farewell and gives her a
taste of her own medicine I want you to
remember
[Music]
because that's how I felt every time you
looked at me however she takes a much
different tone with her father cleaning
him up and thanking him for everything
before smothering him with a pillow she
rolls the projectionist and his car into
the swamp in Norman Bates style and
heads off to her big audition with
everything riding on her success
[Music]
at this point with her bags packed and
her family killed Pearl has bet
everything on the dance audition there
is no plan B she even lets this slip in
front of Mitzi it has to be me
laugh I don't think you meant to say
that out loud Pearl
well if it's not me then I hope it's you
right
to be me while Pearl is focused and a
deadly serious almost like an athlete in
a free game ritual Mitzi is nervous and
begs Pearl to switch places with her she
obliges and Mitzi thanks her telling her
that she's a good friend Emma
of course you are sister-in-law's had to
stick together right this demonstrates
again that Pearl feels things deeply
gets super attached and is hyper aware
of how people see she ultimately just
wants to be loved and appreciated
something she never got from her mom
Pearl finally gets her a moment to shine
she enters the church and takes Center
Stage for real this time once again we
first see things as they actually are
Pearl's not a bad dancer but she's not
professionally trained either then we
see things how Pearl imagines them there
are backup dancers explosions fireworks
and a huge round of applause then it all
disappears thank you
but it's going to be a no
we're looking for something different
today more
All-American younger and blonde someone
would expect Pearl can't believe it she
explains that it's the best dancing
she's ever done and it can't be so in
her delusion she sees the judge
delivering the bad news as her burnt up
mother in a moment of I Told You So
after an unhinged fit of weeping and
wailing uncontrollably Mitzi finds her
outside and takes her home where she
accepts defeat almost rocked never
getting off this Farm she wonders aloud
if there's something really wrong with
her stating that there's something
missing in her that the rest of the
world has Mitzi naively trying to be a
good friend finds out that Pearl never
told Howard about this insecurity and
suggests that Pearl pretended that she's
Howard as she explains everything Mitzi
would come to regret this decision
because what follows is a nearly seven
minute long confession and maybe the
clearest Insight that we have into what
is actually going on in Pearl's head she
confesses that she's angry at Howard
that she cheated on him that she tried
to use him as a way to get off the farm
that she didn't like being pregnant with
Howard's baby and that she's glad that
the pregnancy didn't pan out she envies
his perfect life and men's how her
prayers are never answered she also
expresses jealousy for the pretty girls
in the movie I want what they have so
badly to be perfect
to be loved from as many people as
possible to make up for all my time
spent suffering
time to wake in the middle of the night
and the fear washes over me cause what
if this is it what if this is Right
Where I Belong failure this is part of
what gives Pearl depth as a villain
she's honest and she wants to be loved
just as all people do to some extent
she's full of normal human emotions like
self-pity Envy regret and fear but it
cranked up to 11 in terms of how
fervently she feels them seemingly
without realizing it she moves on from
things she shouldn't have said to things
she really shouldn't have said I'm so
scared that when you finally come home
you'll see me and be frightened like
everyone else is I know what I've done
bad things
terrible awful murderous things she
reveals everything claiming that killing
is easier than you'd think then begs for
forgiveness promising to make things
right and make a life for them on the
farm be enough
just you and me here on this Farm all I
really want is to be loved having such a
hard time without it lately it's the
first time that Pearl has ever expressed
interest in staying on the farm
apparently giving up on her dreams and
judging by how her story plays out she
must have meant it but her proclivity
towards Fame and Beauty would stick with
her over the years finally for the first
time in minutes she looks up at her poor
sister-in-law who is absolutely
shell-shocked Mitzi makes up an excuse
to leave just like the projectionist did
a few hours earlier and pearl recognizes
this immediately and asked Mitzi if
she's frightened of her Mitzi assures
her that all is well but Pearl doesn't
buy it but instead of calling Mitzi out
on the line she takes it one step
further she congratulates her on getting
the part in the dance room Mitzi at
first denies that she got the part but
Pearl insists that she doesn't need to
lie until she relents and tells Pearl
that she got the part it's a little
unclear if she actually did get the part
or if she is once again trying to tell
Pearl what she wants to hear in order to
escape the situation whatever the case
one thing is clear Pearl believes it and
she doesn't like it leading things to
take a dark turn nice kid everything
Pearl tries to assure Mitzi that she
loves Howard and can fix things she begs
her not to tell anybody what she's done
to which Mitzi agrees but not
convincingly enough Pearl chases her
down and murders her with an ax this one
is different though this time she's not
motivated by someone getting in the way
of her stardom or anger of rejection but
rather out of self-preservation she
wants to keep what she's got with Howard
and Mitzi knows too much thanks to their
little role play exercise
is not making the best of what I have
Pearl returns to the basement and does
her best to patch things up with her
dead mother She lays down and combs her
hair using her powerful imagination to
daydream of a life where her mom loved
her and sang her lullabies she's falling
into a state of complete disassociation
from reality in order to continue
thriving in Her Fantasy she chops up
Mitzi and feeds her to Theta the
luckiest Gator on Earth probably then
sets the table for a lovely maggot
infested porch Pig dinner with her
parents corpses her complete mental
breakdown could not have come at a
better time for her husband who had just
been discharged from the war and was on
his way home to discover this horrific
scene when he arrives Pearl does her
best to play it cool but fails miserable
[Music]
I'm so happy you're home Pearl Smiles at
her husband and smiles and smiles and
she cries a little and keeps smiling her
loneliness after Howard went to fight in
the war was the main catalyst that drove
her over the edge and his unexpected
return essentially broke her brain we
don't know for sure what happened next
but we do know that for whatever reason
Howard stuck around for another 61 years
after Howard returns from the horrors of
War only to discover that his wife has
made a horrifying scene of their own
home he presumably helps her hide the
evidence and given that they lived in
the countryside it's unlikely that
anyone would come investigating it's
possible that he just enjoyed working on
the farm and felt it was a sin for a man
to divorce his wife even if she had
murdered her parents his sister and some
movie projectionist that she'd slept
with hopefully for Howard's sake she
spared him those last details or maybe
he stayed with her out of fear of
becoming her next Target or even being
blamed for the murders later on Pearl
reflects on this time which may offer a
much simpler reason for Howard's
compliance there wasn't anything you
went through for me Jack then
the power and beauty
anyway the flu pandemic came to an end
then the Roaring 20s happened followed
by the Great Depression Pearl never
mentions children and we know that she
hated being pregnant so there's no
reason to believe that she and Howard
would have started a family we know that
Pearl was left alone on the farm yet
again when Howard volunteered to fight
in World War II by the time he came home
from that war Pearl was almost 50 years
old so we don't know exactly what
happened in the 30 years after the war
but we know that Pearl succeeded in
Saving what she had with Howard either
way the easiest assumption is that Pearl
remained on the farm with Howard until
we see her again in 1979. Pearl couldn't
hide her Dark Side from Howard so maybe
Howard protected Pearl like her mother
did by keeping her isolated on the farm
where the world wouldn't see her Dark
Side however it would be safe to assume
that Mitzi was not her last victim in
the younger half of her life because 60
years is a long time not to run into a
missionary or a girl scout or a census
Taker and Howard still seems to want to
shelter her even in their Elder years at
some point Howard came down with a heart
condition and eventually grew too old to
do farm work so in the 1970s they
started renting out a guest house for a
little extra income Howard confesses to
Jackson Hole that a Bohemian renter died
for trying to entice Pearl was the other
renter actually trying to entice Pearl
probably not but we see this poor
Bohemian hanging naked from the basement
ceiling later on so we do know that he
was probably murdered did Pearl kill him
for rejecting her did Howard kill him
out of jealousy whatever it was there's
a messed up Dynamic happening on this
farm and things get messed up when a
film crew from Houston rents out the
guest house Howard likely would have
never let them stay if they knew that
they were there to shoot an adult film
considering Pearl's history of delusions
of stardom hurl watches as the crew
pulls up their leader Wayne even does
the shaven haircut thing when he knocks
on the front door foreign
little does he know Pearl and Howard are
both over 80 years old at this point
they can remember when things actually
cost two beds Pearl seems fixated as she
stares longingly at Maxine the young
star of the adult movie threw an
upstairs window this could be because
Maxine looks a lot like Pearl did when
she was younger in fact they look
exactly alike because Mia goth plays
both Pearl and Maxine it's not a subtle
Choice it's history repeating itself
both young women are consumed with their
Obsession to become famous starlets
Pearl and Howard seem to have an
arrangement Howard talks to the renters
and pearl keeps to herself religion
remains a big part of their lives their
TV is constantly tuned into a channel
featuring sermons from a fire and
brimstone preacher who warns of sex
fiends lurking where they least expect
it so when Howard finally meets this
group of young underdressed guests he
doesn't like it especially because he
knows that it might set Pearl off so he
warns the crew to stay away from her my
wife is next door so I would appreciate
a little discretion they assumed he was
just being old-fashioned and protecting
his wife from the indecency but what
they don't understand is that Howard is
actually protecting them from his wife
but Pearl's curiosity is too strong and
she spies on her much younger
doppelganger skinny dipping in theta's
Old swamp where a new gator possibly
theta's grandchild has taken up
residence it's unclear whether Pearl is
interested in Maxine's beauty or the
possibility of seeing her torn apart by
the alligator but I'm guessing it's a
bull Maxine unknowingly escapes and
pearl continues to follow her eventually
they see each other and pearl waves
sheepishly from the porch Maxine wanders
into the house and does a little
snooping if Pearl ever was the happy
Homemaker she said she wanted to be
she's not anymore the place is a mess
Pearl doesn't seem to mind Maxine
snooping because she offers her a
beverage in the creepiest way possible
Maxine accepts the offer and the two sit
at the table and share a wonderful
conversation
okay it's not so much a conversation as
much as it is Pearl staring at Maxine in
deafening silence understandably creeped
out she chugs her lemonade and does
something we know that Pearl can't stand
makes up an excuse to leave Pearl walks
her to the door but not before taking a
trip down memory lane as she sees
herself in Maxine's face what a special
face
[Music]
foreign
Howard arrives home and breaks up the
party so Pearl tells Maxine to leave and
keep their encounter a secret she knows
she's not supposed to be interacting
with the guests just like after seeing
the pretty girls in the movies so many
years ago Pearl once again attempts to
recapture her youthful Beauty by combing
her hair and putting on makeup at some
point although this doesn't happen on
screen Pearl must have communicated to
Howard that she wanted Maxine who they
later refer to as the one and this most
likely happened that afternoon when they
discussed this later on however he still
isn't clear on which girl pearl has her
eye on and it's not clear if he wanted
her to start killing or if he was
actually trying to prevent it luckily
this isn't an analysis of Howard but
it's worth noting that evening she
sneaks out and attempts to live
vicariously as she watches Maxine film
her scene through the cabin window just
as her delusions about her own
self-image ran wild in 1918 she sees
these relations happen and believes that
she can have the same effect that
evening she dresses up and tries to
seduce Howard which he has to turn down
because of his bad heart once again
Pearl can't get what she wants while
those younger and prettier get
everything that she's ever wanted it's
the dance try out all over again later
that night she wakes up unable to
contain her geriatric horniness and ends
up scaring the crap out of the
heartbroken camera guy on his way out of
the farm he gets out of the van to check
on her as if she were a loose patient
wandering the halls of a nursing home
also everyone's favorite song which is
totally not overused in movies and TV is
playing on the radio
little does he know Pearl is the same
desperate attention-starved woman that
she's always been and when he goes to
help she tries to kiss him
[Music]
the camera guy politely declines and
pearl predictably does not handle the
rejection well she stabs him in the neck
23 times to be exact I guess kind of
making good on her promise of showing
him what she's capable of after the
murder Pearl takes a moment to dance in
her own little dream world just like she
was doing when we first met her and also
like the first time we met her she is
unable to stop after just one victim
as Howard searches the grounds for her
Pearl stalks Wayne as he searches the
barn for his missing cameraman he
notices Pearl's movement around the
Barn's perimeter leading him to peek
through a hole in the wall and when he
does Pearl stabs him in the eye with her
weapon of choice a pitchfork later Pearl
walks into the barn casting a devilish
silhouette to finish the job with a
pretty weak Pitchfork stat not bad for
an octogenarian I guess from there she
makes her way into Maxine's bedroom and
climbs into bed with her for a little
skin-to-skin spooning sesh with
strawberry syrup eventually Maxine wakes
up realizes that this is not her
boyfriend and runs out of the room
startling Bobby Lynn the blonde co-star
of the adult film as Pearl heads down to
the pier and Bobby Lin follows her
fearing that the old woman might be
having an episode who would have thought
that these dirty film types would be so
solicitous about the welfare of a crazy
old woman Pearl slaps Bobby Lynn for her
trouble letting her old jealous
Tendencies dictate her behavior why
should you get to have it all
done except be a Pearl shoves
Bobby Lin into the swamp where she
quickly becomes Gator so much for being
a good Samaritan Pearl finally meets up
with Howard he asks her if that was the
want you know I don't want blogs I guess
she still hasn't forgotten about being
snubbed from the church dance group 61
years prior they continue looking for
Maxine in the room where she was
sleeping Howard tells Pearl that he's
got the sound girl Lorraine is trapped
in the basement but Pearl is
disappointed because she wants Maxine
she sees her as special because of their
similarities Pearl asked him to tell her
that she's special although they've
spent many decades together she still
feels the need to be told that she's
loved and admired after all of these
years she's like the world's oldest
pikmi girl so Howard makes love to Pearl
heartbeat damned and not realizing that
Maxine is listening to all of this from
under the bed scarred for life we can't
be sure if Pearl or Howard successfully
finished the job and I don't want to
know but we do know that they eventually
followed the fleeing Maxine back to
their main house where she was
attempting to free Lorraine from the
basement Lorraine tries to make her
Escape out the front door but Pearl and
Howard are ready for her Howard Blaster
with a shotgun right there on the front
porch and immediately begins planning
the cover-up
Pearl watches as Howard moves Lorraine's
body back inside the house but when the
range Twitches ever so slightly it
scares him so badly that he has a heart
attack Pearl runs to his Aid begging
Maxine for help but Maxine responds by
pulling a gun on her which as we've come
to expect sends her adoration towards
the younger girl all the way to the
other end of the spectrum into Blind
Fury Daisy little
at this moment Pearl truly sounds like
her mother and worse yet Maxine looks
and sounds exactly like Pearl did in her
youth I'm a star the whole world
is Gonna Know My Name unfortunately for
Maxine she was not counting on her gun
and being empty and this gives Pearl the
chance to pick up the shotgun and fire
back against her the blast sends Pearl
flying backwards through the screen door
and causes her to break her head all she
can do is beg for hell as Maxine brushes
past and leaves her for dead Pearl's
dying words reflects a life of regrets
of prayers unanswered and dreams
unfulfilled
[Music]
you're not special
it'll all be taken from you
the fact it was for me even in her dying
moments Pearl didn't get what she wanted
she wanted to be loved she wanted to be
a star to be seen and be appreciated
instead she frightened people and at the
end she was physically repulsive to the
crowd she so desperately wanted to be a
part of while we have no way of knowing
exactly what happened on the farm
between World War 1 and 1979. we do know
that at least one unlucky Bohemian was
murdered in that time and Howard was
very aware of what might happen if Pearl
got to interact with the adult film crew
someone as mentally Disturbed as Pearl
doesn't just get better over time
without treatment one thing we do know
is that Pearl's life was ultimately a
tragedy in her final moments before her
skull got flattened under the tires of a
truck she watched Maxine prepare to
leave the farm for good Pearl yearns to
leave so desperately in her youth but
she never got the chance both Pearl and
X were made by a24 if you want to learn
more history from other a24 films check
out my analysis of the vovich from
Robert Eggers The Village by clicking
the video on the left don't forget to
pick up these cz's World medal merch
with the link in the description and
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new Horrors every week ring the death
bell for notifications and I'll see you
in the next video assuming we both
survive